foreign
I want to give you two things one a
systematic way to think about building
uncertain visualizations and two a taste
for how to do it using ggdist Gigi disk
is an r package that extends ggplot2 to
provide three additional geometries each
of these is a composite geometry that
uses the same underlying framework to
understand how to use these it's really
helpful to step back and think about how
to construct uncertainty visualizations
systematically the idea behind ggdist is
that first you would derive an
uncertainty distribution and I don't
really care if your evasion or
frequentist doesn't really matter the
point is you derive an uncertainty
distribution that you can represent in
some way that Gigi just understands
which might be a bunch of samples it
might be a distributional vector it
could be a number of different things
I'm not going to get into the details of
that but if you've derived the
uncertainty distribution what you can
then do is map distributional properties
onto visual channels which is what
ggplot kind of calls Aesthetics this
density plot you have on the left might
be taking the density function and
mapping it onto the thickness of this
slab and you combine it with an interval
which might be say taking two quantiles
and mapping them onto the x-min and x
max of the interval sub geometry and
this is exactly how ggdist thinks about
uncertainty visualization you have stat
slab interval and you're saying I want
to map the PDF so the density function
onto the thickness aesthetic you can
then play around with different
properties like maybe the orientation of
this slab relative to the interval you
might decide that you want the CDF
instead of the PDF you might decide that
you want a gradient plot so you map the
density onto the alpha instead of onto
the thickness of the slab in fact as of
R 4.1 GG just supports the true
gradients that have been added to the
graphics engine so if you output this to
say an SVG or a PDF you can zoom all the
way in you'll get high quality gradients
no matter how far you zoom in we can
create a whole variety of different
geometries just from this same slab
interval family ggdisk provides a bunch
of shortcut geometries but they're all
really derived from the same core
geometry of course the dots interval and
line ribbon are similarly flexible you
can do a bunch of cool different things
with them but I don't really have time
to get into the details of how you would
do all of those different things on the
other hand I did promise Twitter that
this talk would be like a Twitter thread
directly into your skull so for the rest
of this talk I'm just going to jump
through a whole bunch of different fun
examples if you're not going to have
time to tell you how to do any of them
but hopefully it will wet your appetite
and you might go and try it out so let's
do this all right so here's an example
of visualizing a poisson distribution
using a distribution Vector from the
distributional package it knows that
it's a discrete distribution so it gives
you a histogram instead of a density
plot and it also allows you to for
example map the probability onto the
color so you can get this nice little
like gradient effect speaking of
gradients here's a gradient plot this
also shows the use of the Dodge position
from base ggplot with GG disk maybe you
decide that you want to map the CDF onto
it actually this is the complementary
CDF you can think about this as an
infinite number of bar charts with
infinitesimal opacity all stacked on top
of each other other things that you can
do but with mapping Aesthetics at the
sub lab level so here what we're doing
is we're saying oh there's a particular
region of Interest maybe we're
interested in 0 plus or minus 1.5 so we
just map that region onto a different
color Gigi just subdivides the geometry
and then allows you to actually map
colors onto subparts of the geometry
speaking of subdividing the slab here
we're actually using the CDF function
essentially bending the CDF in order to
show 50 80 and 95 intervals on the color
of the slab and so this is a nice
example of using PDF and the CDF
functions together in order to construct
a geometry that would be difficult to do
if you weren't able to use both of them
simultaneously another kind of complex
example of multiple functions being
mapped onto the slab simultaneously The
Fill color is actually varying by group
and then we're using the fill ramp
aesthetic which is an aesthetic within
ggdisk that allows you to independently
ramp the color to white as the color
gets closer to zero speaking of doing
crazy things with densities any
probability list will tell you if you
start taking density functions and
transforming them and you have to
correct for the derivative of the
transformation here we have a log normal
distribution we look at it on the raw
scale it looks like normal if you plot
this on a log scale it should look like
a normal distribution and in fact it
does look like a normal distribution
because GG just figures out the
derivative and it applies the
appropriate correction to the density
everyone loves rain cloud plots these
days Gigi just makes them incredibly
easy to create so we're just combining a
slab geometry with a dots interval
geometry this works because the dots
interval geometry in ggdist
automatically figures out how big the
dots need to be in order to fit this
makes it really easy to combine the dots
geometry with other more complex plot
layouts so here for example this is what
some people call a logit.plot anyway I
hope that it convince you that there's a
lot of cool stuff you can do with ggdist
I haven't even really scratched the
surface here so please give ggdist a try
and for more of the examples from this
talk check out the URL below
foreign
[Music]